the superstar catch of Colorado's
fishing industry is in serious trouble
summer is high season for the state's
more than 2 billion dollar recreational
fishing industry but a disease in the
water is killing rainbow trout even
threatening to wipe out the species Mary
Peterson went to the Black canyons of
Colorado's Gunnison River to learn about
a new effort to fight the disease and
save the trout Joel Evans has been
fishing the stretch of the Gunnison
River in western Colorado for more than
40 years
like most anglers in these parts for him
one species of fish is king the rainbow
trout what's it like to have a rainbow
at the end of this line oh they're fine
they tend to be more active they jump
more but in the 1990s that fight shifted
to one between rainbow trout and a
parasite that invaded Colorado rivers it
causes whirling disease an aquatic
plague where young fish are deformed
swim in circles and die of starvation
what kind of numbers and decrease did
you see at literally a tenfold decrease
ever since Colorado Fish and Wildlife
manager Renzo del piccolo has been
working to keep the rainbow trout alive
through various breeding programs but at
great cost and with only limited success
the rainbow trout is hugely important to
this state
how important is their $1 number fishing
in general it's estimated over 2 billion
dollars to the economy
scientists got a major break when they
discovered a small isolated group of
rainbow trout immune to the disease in
this remote part of the gonna see
there's disagreement over where they
came from but researchers now agree that
their mission is almost biblical turn
these few fish into many nice work
that's why biologist Eric Garduno is
cruising these waters where the immune
trout were discovered capturing healthy
female fish and using them to bring tens
of thousands of offspring that are also
immune to the illness usually we're
gonna have about a day when those
females eggs are ready to be spawned and
collected by us so we're out here kind
of looking for a needle in a haystack
they use this spindly apparatus to send
a weak electric current through the
water that attracts and then stuns the
trout and then it's just up tire netters
to be quick with their net and get those
fish out of the water as quick as
possible the process depends on touch
and time the touch for getting the eggs
out of a female it's usually will be
about a thousand eggs per female and the
time less than a minute to use the male
trout to fertilize the eggs the process
of life is going at that point the
fertilized eggs are brought to a nearby
hatchery where they are cultivated and
raised into healthy rainbow trout ready
to stock rivers all over Colorado we're
starting to develop wild fisheries of
fish that can reproduce and survive on
their own
without our help we know these fish are
resistant to the parasite and we've
actually seen a three-fold increase in
the number or a Mo's we have since we
started doing that well that's good news
for Colorado's economy it means even
more to fishermen like Joel Evans who
know the true value of the sport it's
where it takes you to places like this
Canyon it's the fun of going it's the
adventure sometimes fishing is just kind
of part
so with a little luck and a lot of
science they'll be telling fish stories
around here for decades to come for CBS
this morning Barry Petersen in the black
canyon of the gunnison River Colorado
what a tale yeah put it what a fish tale
it's fascinating fish science and well
done yes and beautiful baby and it's
true I look at the Gunnison River and my
blood pressure drops 20 points just
looking at it does the soundtrack of the
Gunnison River and I feel like taking a
nap
you don't need your blood pressure to
drop do you you're in you're surrounded
by Alex and I hear it's already at this
very low level around you too but then
oh Lord
those pictures were stunning yeah